alright Michelle your besties a big
night what does it mean for you to see
rule leading a series on Netflix
it's spine-chilling spine-tingling from
a firm to see it through to kind of be
around when Ruth was writing it with
Michael Patrick King the concept seeing
it all come to fruition the filming
they're performing the ideas on paper
versus actually happening on Netflix and
it's just an amazing for me I feel like
a mother I'm so proud bruised mom's not
here my mom's out here I'll be the
mother so I'm so excited I got to binge
all 10 episodes early so I've seen the
whole thing I've not seen any and
there's no Michelle visage cameo in this
I was like when's she gonna pop up
when's she gonna pop up what happened
baby season two I think who needed to do
Rouge thing and I'm totally supporting
that and totally loving that you never
know what comes next
yes well I think that season two feels
like good I love that we were sad to see
the talk show did not get picked up are
there any plans to kind of rework that
try it again you know I didn't get sick
it didn't get picked up by Fox that
doesn't you know what I mean that's one
network there's so many ways in so many
places we can go at and so much
potential so we're not giving up on it
it's just that incarnation at that
moment that's what they chose to do but
we still love doing it and we're not
gonna stop we got a lot of projects
coming up anyway we're throwing another
drag race on the burner celebrity drag
race why not I mean why not it's a great
British thing to do have celebrities
participate and this felt like it was
right because this is the type of thing
that celebs want to do and it's amazing
can you tease me a little bit of how it
will be similar to the drag race we know
and how we're switching things up other
than the celebrity aspect I mean you're
gonna have to wait and see I know you're
trying to get gossip not gonna have
because I love my job but it's it's
really good trust me
Ross did tell me we will be a little
star-struck by some of the people
not only that there's some twists and
turns coming at ya that you're really
not going to expect and I think
everybody will be really happy no we
love everything you do we loved watching
drag race UK you do Ireland Scott Allen
you did Strictly Come Dancing would you
ever go do the math singer if I could
judge it I don't want to sing on it I
feel like I've done that
judging call me singing no it was
strictly like you're like I'm done
competing on stuff now quickly what's
the only thing I wanted to do honestly
in all the competition that's the only
show I ever wanted to do and I did it
and I killed it and I'm so proud of it
so I'm good with competing judging is
the way for me would you ever do dancing
in the u.s. dance with the Stars called
you up would you do it again I had the
best time of my life doing Strictly you
really can't
especially when you went far because
it's kind of not fair but then again
Nicole Scherzinger did it she's a
professional dancer so I'll do it yes
it's a booking
[Music]